From the moment you resign,...
...expect attitudes toward you to change; it'll be as if you have left already.
It's your choice whether or not to tell your co-workers.
Remember, though,...
...that they will only hear the truth from you - management may explain your departure differently...
...and will not admit to any wrongdoing.
Irrespective of contract, the actual leaving date may not be up to you.
You may be asked to leave immediately, because you could be seen as a security risk.
ID and company credit cards will be revoked, and passwords and locks changed.
Make sure you hand in everything because you don't want to be blamed for...
...anything that goes wrong after you give notice.
Clear out your desk and take all personal things a day or so before you announce your departure,...
...because you may be escorted out and not have a chance to return to your desk.
These are today's realities.